This video is brought to you by surf shark, VPN
Michael here today,
we're talking about the patriarch of everyone's favorite four fingered family,
master of annoyed, Grun, swaggy schemes, and questionable child-rearing methods.
The one and only Homer Simpson Homer is the center of the
Simpson's world, providing it with many of its most memorable moments,
catchiest.
Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Margie.
I mean that may our T and C.
Just advice about the importance of not trying.
Kids. You tried your best and you failed miserably.
The lesson is never try.
Some things happened to Homer,
something that turned him from a central figure in pop culture to an
afterthought for most television viewers.
So how exactly did Homer fall from grace and take the Simpsons down with him?
Let's find out in this wisecrack edition on Homer Simpson,
what went wrong and spoiler alerts for a show that's almost old enough to run
for president. Now, before we dive deeper,
I'm going to give a shout out to this week's sponsor surf shark,
VPN privacy on the internet may feel non-existent these days,
but if VPN may put your mind at ease, it encrypts information.
So you're protected from hackers getting a hold of your data.
What is great about surf shark is that it is more than just a VPN since it comes
with additional features that can protect you online hack lock ID protection
alerts you. If one of your email addresses or passwords are leaked,
it also includes a blind search,
a tool that can be used to free yourself of targeted ads, cookies,
and any other data collection that might happen while you're online.
The best part is that it can run on all my devices.
So I know that I'm always secure, whether it be my phone laptop,
or even my PS4 surf shark has a 30 day money back guarantee.
So you can check it out. Risk-free go to surf shark.deals/wisecrack,
or hit the link in the description,
protect yourself online and download surf shark VPN today.
Use the promo code wisecrack and get an 83% discount with three months for free.
Now back to the show. Now some background,
the Simpsons first hit the airwaves all the way back in 1989,
modeling itself on the wholesome family sitcom,
which has dominated the small screen over the preceding decade.
It's centered largely around the father slash husband,
as he dealt with the trials and tribulations of everyday life.
Fit. you fit.
Yeah.
Despite being bright yellow cartoon characters,
this Simpson's clan provided a more honest look at the modern American family.
They offered a sharp contrast to the pretty five version of domestic bliss,
which live action sitcoms had been serving up. They may have crazy hair,
but with their bickering, belching and couch centric lifestyle,
this Simpsons were much more like you and me than any other family on TV,
but who was Homer. Anyway,
even when he didn't have his hands around his son's throat,
Homer made for a very different kind of TV dad than his predecessors. You know,
those kindly patriarchs of growing pains or family ties for all patients and
fatherly wisdom, short-tempered lazy and kind of dim.
Homer was made more in the angry white male mold of earlier shows.
Think Archie bunker or the honeymooners Ralph Kramden except without the
explicit bigotry or the constant threat of spousal abuse.
His flaws made him more accessible and thus more relatable because he was
basically just a regular guy who found himself constantly overwhelmed by.
Do OCO and solutions.
To all of life's problems.
Despite his shortcomings, he had managed to clot together the life,
which TV had been teaching all Americans to aspire to since the fifties, a wife,
two and a half kids, a house in the suburbs and two cars in the driveway,
but he was barely able to hold it together. Each day,
saw him dragging himself into a job. He hated to pay off a mortgage.
He couldn't afford before coming home to the family whose problems.
He didn't really understand all while he would rather just sit on the couch or
go out for a few beers. This was in keeping with the ethos of the show,
which offered a more skeptical vision of the world than the wholesome likes of
family ties or leave it to Beaver.
It's a world where most people are prone to selfishness and outright stupidity.
But we're very, very busy down here. Hey, take me.
Daily. Life is full of minor. Indignations that cause major outbreaks.
If we it'll make you feel any better,
I've learned that life is one crushing defeat. After another,
until you just wished Flanders was dead.
And while Homer may be sympathetic, the writers don't let them off the hook,
making it clear that he's responsible for a lot of his own problems.
Tick is perpetual rivalry with his neighbor, Ned Flanders,
a man who bends over backwards to be nice to Homer only to receive a tirade of
abusive petty vengeance and unreturned belongings in Rome.
Past instances in which I prefer to like you were fraudulent.
Oh, well, I'll just have to try harder.
Thanks for grabbing back.
We get why Ned bothers Homer so much. He makes living a happy,
healthy life appear so easy. Hi, diddly.
Flanders.
But Homer's resentment. Doesn't justify being a jerk.
So his schemes almost always blow up.
Take that time before it's Ned to go through with a bet which we'll see them
both mowing the lawn and their wife's Sunday,
finest only to net is completely unembarrassed while Homer is mortified.
But that doesn't mean Homer wasn't capable of many redemptions.
When he actually does succeed in seriously upsetting Flanders.
He feels bad about it and tries to put things right,
like his last minute effort to rescue the left. Tori.
Hallmark affordable track housing made us neighbors, but you made us friends.
Point is in the earlier seasons. Homer's bad behavior.
Basically always catches up with them.
Hi Halima. I brought you.
He gets super mad about something and refuses to back down or become so bored
with his daily life that he goes on some ill fated adventure.
He might destroy the town to avoid taking out the trash or gained 61 pounds to
avoid work or randomly switch careers on a Lark.
That's it. You people have stood in my way long enough.
I'm going to cone college.
The consequences are most serious. One Homer's selfishness hurts his own family.
We have some great plans.
Well, I'm afraid I had some great plans to spend it on beer.
Is although he might be a slobbish partner and emotionally unavailable father
Homer really does love his wife and children.
So how do the early Simpson seasons reconcile Homer's buffoonery with his real
emotional stakes by being genuine,
many of the Simpsons sweetest moments come when a Homer realizes he's messed up
and then tries his best to fix it.
Like the classic scene at the end of Lisa's substitute.
When Homer goes from room to room,
listening to his family's problems and trying to cheer them up,
his chat with leads has become especially beloved because of the way Homer owns
up to all of his shortcomings and admits how lucky he is to have his family.
It's a perfect demonstration of the softer sweeter side of Homer,
which balances out his angrier more of-ish behavior.
Maybe I can't explain all this, but I can fix your dollhouse for you.
Well,
Homer might represent a more cynical take on what an every man really looks
like. He was never just the butt of the joke. The show is insane. Wow.
Look how lazy and ridiculous everybody is.
But something more like we're all kind of goofy,
but we might be okay if we look out for each other, how's your marriage.
Jamie's usual. Perfect. Imundo.
This Simpsons had a lot of fun highlighting the various, a packer season,
inadequacies of modern day America and how far it all felt from the idealized
vision of the classic sitcoms, but it always did.
So from a place of genuine warmth,
it always came back to the decency beneath the.
There are pictures. I keep them where I need the most cheering up.
Showing on the quality gradually began to drop off.
And fans had pointed to any number of culprits, some blame,
certain showrunners for misunderstanding the series while others believe it was
more of a too many cooks scenario. As the writing staff expanded,
whatever the reason something had happened to the show and specifically to
Homer, the issue isn't that he became dumber or wackier though.
He did it's that he became more.
Yeah. Grandfather is super lame. I mean, if he wasn't a terrible father,
what's my excuse for this.
Anytime, a sit-com runs for season after season,
the characters gradually become more exaggerated versions of themselves.
Fraiser crane goes from pretentious,
suave socialite to pompous buffoon on friends, Joey Tribbiani.
He goes from slightly vapid, pretty boy to a zoo Lander.
So parody of himself and community's Brita Perry.
It goes from impassion student activists to simply the worst.
You seem smarter than me. When I met you,
we see the same thing happened to Homer. He becomes a caricature of himself,
both visually and emotionally.
His IQ dwindles has temper short and he goes from a put upon schmuck to an
all out before noon,
getting himself into increasingly outrageous scrapes and the show matched
Homer's gradual drift towards absurdity, focusing less on a real life.
Domestic troubles in favor of zany or plot lines and globe trotting adventures.
This wasn't necessarily a deal breaker for a long time.
A Homer retained enough self-awareness to make this new iteration of the
character work.
You mean? I think this is crazy, but eventually.
Homer's worst tendencies began to take over.
Remember how Homer used to make amends after hurting his family.
Compare that to this slightly later example,
when he's caught on camera bemoaning his familial burdens.
Marriage is like a coffin and each kid is another nail. Once again.
And Homer has acted callously towards his loved ones,
but this time he shows no remorse and is rewarded for his deliciousness with a
trip to rock camp.
The viewer is no longer being asked to care about how crappily he's treated his
family, his selfish claim that they ruined his life basically goes unchallenged.
And the episode moves on this incident is typical of the new Homer known to fans
as jerk Homer, and they're not wrong.
He becomes increasingly obnoxious destructive and just plain mean-spirited.
At the same time,
the show seems increasingly less interested in having him face any consequences
for his behavior. Later episodes revolve around Homer pulling crap,
like pretending to kill principal Skinner's mother scamming the town with the
fake parking meter and even wiping out Springfield with an EMP in season one,
Homer was so devastated by his own failures that he almost killed himself for
all his flaws and goofball antics.
The show made certain that his actions and choices mattered jerk.
Homer is more of an all-purpose rodeo clown,
ready to do whatever outrageous thing might raise a laugh up to and including
framing Marge for a DUI.
Clearly the show has significantly changed the way it views its leading man and
how it wants to use him as Homer moves from hapless,
but kindhearted OEF to rampaging bully.
The Simpson starts playing for a notably different sort of labs rather than
depicting the flaws and foibles of everyday life with both skepticism and
optimism like in its early days,
the show descends into a detached kind of cynicism.
You'll be so kind as just dart my car for me. I'm going to Moe's.
Woo. So how did this happen.
To make sense of Homer's transformation?
It helps to look at the broader cultural landscape and how it's changed over the
course of the Simpson's run. When the show first arrived,
it was a real trailblazer,
not just because it was a prime time adult animated series,
but because it provided a much rougher around the edges picture of family life
than we'd seen before. And in the process,
it ushered in a new generation of adult animation that took things a step
further, you know, shows like South park and family guy,
which traded a shock and all style of comedy where the absolute lack of empathy
is largely the point.
Hey, Kevin, give me, give me mic.
She's writing it right there.
While these shows had sent a mental moments,
their comedy was mostly pretty cynical,
disavowing everyone in everything in favor of the next punchline to enjoy them a
level and antics of Eric Cartman and early Stewie Griffin.
You had to treat their world as total sandboxes,
not places with real emotional stakes.
This opened up all kinds of new comedic avenues while basically precluding any
potential for sincerity.
Help me. I'll be one can now be here. My only hope. All right, now,
why do I click click preferences?
Fundamentally,
this humor relies on you not really caring about the characters too much. Do.
My actions have consequences.
Whether it was intentionally aping rival shows or not,
the Simpsons has gradually followed this path by turning Homer into a much more
cynical character.
All his earthly attachments are pretty much gone gross out jokes about
bedwetting or outrageous gags about demonic threesomes.
Three way. You me and merge even demon. You.
Are now par for the course.
It's like the writers are hoping that the sheer absurdity or edginess of what
he's doing will be enough to get a laugh.
This new iteration of the Simpsons keeps everything at a kind of ironic distance
telling the audience to emotionally disengage so it can crack another edgy joke.
But this all comes at the cost of the sweet moving moments we got from classic
Homer. He still has his trademark annoyed grunt and love of Duff beer.
But beyond that, there's not really much of the old Homer left.
We're not saying that sitcoms like the Simpsons need to be preachy or to end
every episode within. I learned something today, speech,
but there is a real cost to removing the emotional anchors from their character.
While Homer might now be able to go toe to toe with Peter Griffin in a brutal
fistfight, it's harder to care about it because it's harder to care about him.
If there is a lesson to be learned from Homer's fall from grace,
it might be that selling your character soul for easier quicker.
Gags is a pathway of diminishing returns. Of course,
some reason cartoons are remarkable for the refusal to descend into full blown
cynicism. While BoJack horseman is dark, even nihilistic,
the characters are earnestly trying to become better.
And then there's Bob's burgers, which keeps the belt.
Her family's love for each other front and center,
no matter how crazy things get.
But what do you think wisecrack is adult animation best when drowned and booze
and cynicism, or do you miss the good natured buffoonery of classic Homer?
Let us know in the comments big, thanks to our patrons for your support,
smash that subscribe button like Homer shotgunning,
a cold can of Duff and as always, thanks for watching later.
[Inaudible].